plaît bien avec cette victoire peut être
historique de boris johnson en tout cas
impressionnante dans son ampleur puisque
depuis les grandes années margaret
thatcher jamais le parti conservateur
n'avait obtenu une telle majorité à la
chambre et boris johnson à la fois
premier ministre et patron du parti ne
gâchait pas son plaisir hier tout en
restant égal à lui-même et aux bobos
ob c'est que deviendra cette victoire de
boris johnson alors même qu'il avait on
va dire les milieux dirigeants
contrôlaient un peu au sens large à la
fois les principaux dirigeants de
l'europe qui était plutôt opposés aux
briques site
les milieux d'affaires quelques huiles
de son parti d'ailleurs comme l'ancien
premier ministre john major
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une victoire
du populiste ou pas cette ce scrutin
d'hier
moi je veux bien que vous le qualifier
ainsi
c'est tout simplement la confirmation
qu'il ya une opinion publique
britannique qui est favorable
effectivement breakes site alors que
depuis des mois on nous expliquait qu'
il s'en mordait les doigts et qu' il
voulait revenir sur cette sueur sur
cette décision qui aurait été prise sous
influence de faradje je crois que il y a
là un contexte vraiment mais blake était
encore plus de briques sitter que que
comme ça oui mais ils ont quand même
réussi à trouver puisque dans 300
circonscription faraj n'a pas présenté
de candidat pour permettre par le mode
de scrutin uninominal à un tour en
angleterre qui est un très bon mode de
scrutin que je soutient personnellement
eh bien il a
et bien permis effectivement au candidat
conservateur de l'emporter vous avez dit
vous l'avez dit c'est une c'est une très
grande victoire des conservateurs c'est
surtout aussi le plus mauvais score du
labour depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
donc c c'est d'autant plus intéressant
elle a dit oui c'est impressionnant le
peuple n'est plus à gauche apparemment
au royaume uni le pays votre plus beau
coup travailliste en fait pour moi ce ne
sont pas minces et les élites qui sont
visés c'est les élites les îles publicis
qui a gagné ses arguments populistes et
là ça nous envoie ça nous renvoie à ce
qui se passe en angleterre de son public
vite donc là on vient de confirmer que
les anglais étaient plutôt pour pour
pour le break vite avec l'écho fait aux
etats unis c'est à dire que je pense que
saab d'un père occupait aussi écho à
l'élection de la prochaine élection
américaine avec le candidat un candidat
populiste qui développe cette idée de ce
type d'arguments et qui fait écho dans
la population aujourd'hui c'est pas on
n'est pas
c'est pas une confrontation c'est pas le
peuple contre les élites mais les
arguments populistes ont beaucoup d'écho
j'ai du basket je pense que la victoire
écrasante en effet de bobby johnson est
due à trois facteurs d'abord c'est la
force de son message qui était extrait
extrêmement clair il a fait une campagne
très une très bonne campagne avec un
message d'une limpidité totale
c'est-à-dire enough assez ça suffit ça
suffit on va faire ce break site et
beaucoup de gens qui n'étaient pas
forcément briques sites se sont résignés
on tresse ont adhéré à l'idée que de
toute façon ce bric site devait avoir
lieu
et finalement la lassitude la durée
l'embourbement du bric site a plaidé
finalement pour le bric site plutôt que
contre alors on aime on pourrait
s'attendre à au fait ben voilà c'est à
dire tellement longtemps les gens vont
se dégoûter du break 6 mars et le
contraire en fait c'est à dire que la
durée l'embourbement à pousser les gens
vers le brésil pour en finir de la fin
du message
il a bénéficié aussi d'un adversaire il
faut dire jérémy corps been qui a fait
une campagne catastrophique qui lui a
plaidé pour un deuxième référendum
donc a perdu tous les électeurs qui
étaient propres sites puisque les
électeurs probable si vous n'avez pas
voté pour quelqu'un qui proposait un
deuxième référendum parce que le travail
est le même et était divisée donc la fin
de match catastrophique
et puis évidemment l'antisémitisme qui
ronge le labor et puis un programme
extrêmement radical
il faut se souvenir que j'arrive
terminer quelques années était louée
comme la le renouveau de la gauche
radicale après les années après
l'effondrement la social démocratie
partout en europe c'était vraiment la
figure admiré par jean luc mélenchon etc
on voit bien que là c'est un
effondrement total et c'est une leçon
pour les états unis aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que quand on voit les candidats de
la gauche radicale sont en train de
faire un tabac pendant les primaires
démocrates
est-ce que
la défaite de jarry garmin peut-être un
avertissement c'est ça va être
intéressant à suivre
et enfin je pense qu'il ya aussi une
évolution du contenu de du des
conservateurs qui ont évolué et
finalement d'un break site qui était au
départ même libre exit heures au sein du
parti conservateur était très libéraux
ils disent on va faire un break site
pour faire une sorte de singapour 1
un paradis fiscal de l'angleterre et qui
ils ont ils ont mis du social dans leur
campagne et du coup ils ont regagné le
lectorat populaire et rappelez vous que
les conservateurs ont fait 9 % aux
européennes c'est à dire à peu près le
score de la droite actuellement en
france aux européennes ils sont passés
de 9 % à cette majorité écrasante parce
que l'on croit pas sa rage avec son
parti exactement
ils ont fait la crise à la crise sociale
qui a gagné les élections voilà 3 mios
humaniste et ils ont ils ont aussi mais
du social dans la campagne c'est à dire
que boris johnson à me fait une croix
sur le thatchérisme a fait une campagne
avec beaucoup de mesure voire la santé
notamment engager des dizaines de
milliers d'infirmières par exemple dans
les hôpitaux et on voit qu'il a réussi
comme ça à récupérer l'électorat
populaire et le volet au labo est la
gauche mais c'est très intéressant et
c'est une leçon aussi encore une fois
pour la droite française
rien ne serait ce qu'à votre avis les
britanniques ont pu voter contre leur
intérêt économique en se prononçant pour
le break 6 c'est à dire en fait en
faisant passer la politique avant avant
leur porte monnaie sur faire attention
avec ce type de jugement parce que
l'économie se peut avoir un regard sur
les effets du bric site
la réalité c'est que le président n'a
pas encore eu lieu donc bien malin qui
saura dire ce qui se passera
économiquement socialement après le
brésil fois qu'a d'abord politiquement
deux enseignements sur ce qui vient de
se passer hier premier enseignement
c'est que le bleu brigitte aura bien
lieu
boris johnson a en effet réussi à
convertir le score du référendum de 2016
en vote pour les conservateurs
il a capitalisé sur ce vote anti union
européenne mais aussi vote de rejet
envers la mondialisation vote de rejet
envers l'immigration venus de l'est
un vote notamment sur ce que vous
soulignez les enjeux de santé donc il a
réussi ce pari là qui était le pari
d'une droite conservatrice
deuxièmement pour l'union européenne le
brésil aura bien lieu ce qui est d'une
certaine manière une clarification sakho
d'ores et déjà on sait que boris johnson
aura une majorité à la chambre des
communes et pourra
s'ils le souhaitent comme illicite est
ici était engagé faire passer un accord
c'est-à-dire un président avec un deal
deuxième enseignement me semble-t-il
c'est l'erreur stratégique qu'a réalisé
le labor en suivant la ligne de jeremy
corbyn c'est le score le plus faible
effectivement depuis 1935 40 sièges qui
ont été perdus à la chambre des communes
quand on regarde la carte est très
intéressant vous avez le nord de
l'angleterre
les villes industrielles qui avaient
déjà voté pour leurs exit et qui cette
fois ci ont carrément voter boris
johnson
alors que pour certaines c'était la
première fois qu'elle voter conservateur
c'était des villes qui étaient labor
depuis peut-être un peu plus d'un siècle
et qui avaient voté leur exit est donc
cette bascule comme je le disais du
référendum s'est traduite aujourd'hui en
bascule vers un vote conservateur et et
donc il a perdu des voix sur sa gauche
il a aussi perdu des voix progressistes
parce que tout l'électorat pro europe
s'est pas sentie représenté par la
campagne jeremy corby napus entre
guillemets s'éparpille électoralement
sur du vote libdems sur du vote
écologiste et donc avec ce mode de
scrutin à un tour
ça a permis aux conservateurs de passer
dans certaines circonscriptions succès
les beaufs et ses plus gros scores dans
les grosses métropoles chinoises nation
très riche multiculturaliste intégré etc
la mondialisation et perd les classes
populaires donc c'est la voilà donc pour
conclure si elles souhaitent être
majoritaire la gauche britannique
accueillera comme une bonne nouvelle le
retrait de jeremy corps been pour les
prochaines élections
guillaume bernard reda didi faisait une
comparaison entre le positionnement de
boris johnson et celui du donald trump
vous êtes un spécialiste des droits pour
vous c'est la même droite c'est de la
non c'est pas la même droite parce que
c'est pas le même contexte
alors pardon évidemment moi je suis
historien et donc je pense que le
contexte compte beaucoup
en revanche je fus le droit merci en
revanche il ya une chose qui est
certaine c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
théoriser avec le concept de mouvements
dextrogyre je suis persuadé que
désormais la pression idéologique vient
par la droite du spectre politique et
que
depuis l'effondrement du mur de berlin
depuis l'effondrement du régime
collectiviste et bien c'est désormais
des thématiques venant de la droite qui
s'impose dans le débat public
et en l'occurrence qu'est ce que l'on
voit on voit que il y à une convergence
et idéologiques et sociologique
permettant à la droite de devenir
majoritaire et de s'imposer de manière
très réelle
lorsqu'il y a un discours qui est
clairement conservateur et populaire est
pas lorsque la droite s'imagine qu'elle
a besoin d'être libéral ou de faire des
concessions idéologique à la gauche pour
pouvoir gagner les élections et donc
posté de domaine qu'un français pour ce
qui est de poster de donald trump il
assume le protectionnisme de manière de
manière certaine et les enjeux
identitaires était assez absent en tout
cas de cette campagne lancée par un papa
du premier break site mais cette
campagne là oui sauf que pour le
référendum
take back contrôle qui était le slogan
génial que faraj avait inventé c'était
aussi bien le contrôle des frontières
que le contrôle je dirais de l'avenir
démocratiquement parlant et c'est donc
il y a quand même de manière
sous-jacente quand même saison je sais
c'est jean de saison je la et puis
disons le livre aussi le succès d'un
boris johnson ou d'un donald trump ça
tient aussi évidemment à leur qualité
johnson fait le pitre mais il est
intellectuellement de très bonne qualité
trump peut-être et n'est pas aussi
intellectuel que johnson
mais enfin ils n'arrivent pas au stade
où il est on n'arrive pas au stade où il
est sans une certaine forme
d'intelligence quand même
donc voilà il ya la qualité des
candidats toi même qui explique aussi le
résumé d'accord mais la différence comme
entre trump et johnson johnson
appartient à l'élite politique
intellectuel britannique il a fait les
plus grands écoles il est alors que
trame est un trublion qui vient de les
laisser
oui dans les économies mais par héritage
mais et donc c'est là où johnson est
intéressant parce qu'il réconcilie le
peuple et les élites
là où trump n'a pas encore je vous donne
la vie de nos internautes
on vous a posé la question depuis ce
matin sur lefigaro.fr êtes vous
satisfait de la victoire de boris
johnson bien si oui à 59% vous êtes
assez nombreux à vous être prononcée sur
ce sujet puisqu'il ya une vague un peu
plus de 28000 votant sur le site du
figaro depuis ce matin on rappelle que
ce sont des prises de position et pas
des sondages puisqu'il n'est pas un
échantillon représentatif forcément la
population française quelques
commentaires celui de nicole qui nous
dit que c'est une victoire de la
démocratie
si qui considère que le bric si
n'empêchera en rien les échanges
commerciaux et puis kris kross qui
reprend un des thèmes déjà traiter
autour de cette table pour dire que les
pauvres du nord on voit tes breakes site
eux qui avant voter travailliste ryan
désarmement ajouter quelque chose c'est
tout à fait juste alors rien il ya un
dernier élément qu'on n'a pas encore
abordé concernant le cas de l'ecosse
scam intéressant parce que le smp le
parti national écossais a fait 49 sièges
sur 148 pendant sur 59
on se souvient du référendum en 2014 ils
sont antibes rexie temps rappellent
qu'ils veulent à tout prix rester dans
l'union européenne que le le brésil aura
lieu la question est de savoir si la
sortie de l'école du royaume uni aura
aussi lieu
c est ce que le snpi qui aujourd'hui est
largement majoritaire auprès des
électeurs écossais va redemander et
mettre la pression sur boris johnson
pour avoir un nouveau référendum sur la
sortie du royaume-uni pour rester dans
l'union européenne et donc ça peut être
aussi un des prix que paiera en
l'occurrence la coalition conservatrice
on verra mais je trouve que c'est assez
intéressant analyse et je pense que ça
va ça va rebondir dans les mois qui
viennent
bernard on aime bien la politique
française ici alors est-ce qu'on pouvait
développer un petit peu ce que vous nous
disiez à l'instant à votre avis quelles
sont les leçons que les républicains en
france pourrait tirer de cette victoire
de boris johnson qu'est-ce que johnson a
fait et qui font pas concret je crois
pas que ce sont que les républicains qui
doivent tirer des leçons
je crois que la fracture idéologique et
social elle traverse tous les partis
politiques qui se situe sur la droite du
spectre politique que ce n'est pas il
n'y a pas d'équivalence si vous voulez
automatique qui en fait il n'ya plus
d'équivalence automatique entre le parti
gaulliste et le parti conservateur
je crois que les fractures le concerne
aussi bien le lr que le rassemblement
national et que en l'occurrence la
convergence idéologique elle est
possible à condition évidemment qu'il y
ait une clarification des prises de
position c'est à dire que l'on comprenne
bien évidemment que le libéralisme
engage non seulement la question des
libertés économiques la question de la
fiscalité mais aussi la question je
dirais social est que le libéralisme en
tant que philosophie est une doctrine
qui pense qu'il n'existe pas de valeur
en soi et donc ne pas réduire le
libéralisme à l'acte enfin la question
fise le libéralisme à la question
fiscale mais que par ailleurs
effectivement il y a aussi des enjeux
liés à la maintien du corps social à la
pérennité du corps social tel qu'il a
été donné et
et par l'histoire et dont nous sommes
aujourd'hui les héritiers et que donc
par conséquent moi je ne crois pas que
ni l hernie le rassemblement national
seront en capacité
l'un ou l'autre est même l'un avec
l'autre
si jamais un jour il devait y avoir des
alliances de l'emporter mais que c'est
une recomposition du spectre politique
une réorganisation sur une clarification
doctrinal qui permettrait et la
convergence idéologique et la
convergence sociale donc moi je crois
pas du tout aux alliances entre les
actuels appareils est d'ailleurs
l'émergence d' emmanuel macron la grande
coalition réalisé par le maquereau nisme
montre bien et le dégoût que les
français ont vis-à-vis et la défiance
qui l'ont vis-à-vis des partis des
actuels partis politiques nécessite
obligatoirement la recomposition et la
réorganisation des partis c'est qu'en
france la droite est divisée entre une
droite élitaire une droite populaire
droite populaire c'est le rassemblement
national et la droite élitaire
aujourd'hui c'est l'air et que donc à
cette division qui n'existe pas au
royaume uni parce que je pense que
l'élite au royaume uni et par son
histoire beaucoup moins déconnecté du
peuple parce qu'il ya eu la révolution
française jusqu'à pas eu cette cette
brisure et il ya il ya une espèce de
sens du devoir et du patriotisme qui
n'emporte malgré tout chez les élites
requis 10 mois voilà le peuple a voulu
briques site nous allons l'assumer
nous allons prendre non accepter la
décision du peuple et nous allons
assumer jusqu'au bout sans mépriser ce
que ce qu'a dit notre peuple et je pense
qu'il ya une vraie différence de
mentalité entre les élèves britanniques
et françaises c'est aussi le mode de
scrutin ce que vous décrivez un qui
force au bipartisme qui en fait qui
favorise favorise le fait d'avoir quatre
partis dans les divisions de l'épaule
droite et de gauche
moi je suis favorable au mode de scrutin
à un tour comme l'était michel debré
du coup je suis plus je suis tout seul
maintenant à le défendre comme nissan a
obligés à considérer le plus proche
comme étant un allié potentiel et non
pas comme étant un ennemi et ça oblige à
composer
en faisant des concessions réciproques
si vous le voulez bien on revient en
france pour parler de l'actualité
sociale et du conflit en cours